und jetzt das heute journal
mit kai soll richter und christian
sievers guten abend deutschland auf der
suche nach der richtigen therapie die
bisherige hat noch nicht wirklich
angeschlagen
dazu kommt die symptome sind klar die
exakten ursachen aber zunehmend
umstritten
und was das ganze noch mal komplizierter
macht ist dr gleich mehrere koryphäen
daran herum
das ist die lage nach drei wochen teil
shutdown im november die neuinfektionen
explodieren nicht mehr aber sie gehen
auch nicht wirklich nachhaltig zurück
warum das ist die große frage
heute haben die ministerpräsidentinnen
und präsidentin der bundesländer
untereinander konferiert sie wollen
müssen für kommende woche ein konzept
fertig haben mit welchen regeln dieses
land in den dezember geht richtung
weihnachten und silvester eines scheint
heute bereits klar
einfacher wird es nicht mathis feldhoff
hier werden sie derzeit gesammelt die
vorschläge aus den ländern mit einem v
am anfang vw verbote verlängerung oder
verschärfung im dienstsitz des berliner
bürgermeisters entsteht das papier das
man der kanzlerin vorlegt verlängern
scheint schon konsens verschärfen
vielleicht auch es gibt keinen anlass zu
einer entwarnung auch nicht zu einem
teil entwarnung sondern wir müssen uns
leider mit der tatsache vertraut machen
dass der london verlängert wird
deutschlandweit sind die zahlen noch zu
hoch das hat auch damit zu tun dass wir
wirklich hot spots haben die ganz ganz
hohe instanzen haben wo dieser november
shutter und nicht ausreicht und vor
allem dort muss es zu schärferen regeln
kommen rund drei kilometer sind es zu
dem ort an dem am mittwoch wieder
gefeilscht wird drei kilometer durch
berlin von den ländern zum bund von den
ministerpräsidenten die letzte woche
noch gezögert haben zur kanzlerin
die längst zu härterem bereit war im
kanzleramt wartet man jetzt sollen noch
die bundesländer mal was vorschlagen am
mittwoch soll es eine geschlossene eine
gemeinsame antwort geben ganz zufrieden
wirkt die bundesregierung aber heute
noch nicht
tatsache ist dass wir noch nicht so weit
sind wie wir gerne
kommen wären durch die kontakt
beschränkungen und deshalb hat ja auch
jeder dass es noch verlängerung geben
muss doch wie lange die verlängerung
tatsächlich dauern soll
wie lange restaurants und bars noch
geschlossen bleiben ist offen
die masken pflicht in schulen soll
möglicherweise auf alle altersklassen
ausgeweitet werden und der
präsenzunterricht in den oberstufen und
berufsschulen könnte reduziert werden
kontakt beschränkung als allheilmittel
dennoch wirkt es nur wie eine bekämpfung
der symptome
aktuell ist das infektionsgeschehen sehr
tief fuß viele menschen wissen gar nicht
wo sie sich angesteckt haben und
dementsprechend ist es auch schwierig
ganz gezielt maßnahmen zu ergreifen um
eben diese speziellen schritte weil
diese speziellen situationen zu
unterbinden längst verläuft die
konfliktlinien nicht mehr zwischen
parteien oder koalitionen zwischen bund
und ländern sondern zwischen den
bundesländern mit hohen fallzahlen und
denjenigen mit wenigen es wäre
wünschenswert wenn eine regionale
differenzierung möglich wäre es gibt
halt region im nordosten wo das von dem
ihr geschehen völlig anders ist als in
bayern beispielsweise härter länger
differenzierter die stichworte für die
debatte am mittwoch sind gesetzt das ist
dadurch verständlicher und
nachvollziehbarer wird müssen bund und
länder jetzt noch beweisen
herter länger differenzierter das sind
die stichworte berlins regierender
bürgermeister michael müller spd ist der
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hermeler
guten abend schön wenn man sie haben die
aufgabe jetzt einen gemeinsamen
beschluss vorzubereiten die details
kommen am mittwoch wenn sie damit der
bundesregierung zusammen sitzen aber
härter länger differenzierter trifft es
das schon mal ganz gut
ja wir wissen alle dass wir noch mehr
tun müssen wir haben schon viel erreicht
und auch die maßnahmen aus dem november
mehr wirkung gezeigt das ist ja nicht
weiter nach oben gegangen
aber wir wissen eben bis zu der phase wo
dann auch der impfstoff wo medikamente
und zur verfügung stehen haben wir noch
viel zu tun wir sehen die situation in
den krankenhäusern und intensivstationen
und das eint uns auch dass wir gerade
eben bei den themen die auch
angesprochen worden wir wahrscheinlich
im moment noch nicht lockerungen oder
mehr möglichkeiten zulassen können das
heißt also restaurants theater
sporthallen bleiben zu kontakt
beschränkungen werden möglicherweise
sogar noch verschärft ja wobei es
natürlich jetzt schon auch eine rolle
spielt dass wir regional angepasst
vorgehen wollen es ist ja so wir haben
bundesweit ein problem alle miteinander
nirgendwo sind die zahlen wirklich gut
aber sie sind eben den eigenen
bundesländern oder regionen doch besser
als an anderen
und dass man dann gegebenenfalls bei
einer weiterhin positiven entwicklung
auch früher dinge möglich machen kann
als in anderen ländern als an anderen
hotspots dass es durchaus auch eine
überlegung die jetzt festgehalten wurde
gut aber er generell wird auf jeden fall
nicht einfacher lassen sie uns über den
zeitrahmen noch in gilt das ganze jetzt
über weihnachten hinaus gilt es erstmal
nur für die nächsten wochen gilt es für
den gesamten winter oder bleiben wir bei
wie ihre kollegin schwesig anmahnte bei
so einer salamitaktik der letzten wochen
nein überhaupt nicht das ist ja genau
das was wir auch verhindern wollten und
deswegen hat so einen sehr detaillierten
abstimmungsprozess bisher schon gegeben
ich habe in den letzten tagen mit fast
allen ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten gesprochen
wir haben einen ständigen austausch und
wir wollen ja mindestens in phasen jetzt
auch diverse schritte festhalten bis zur
weihnachtszeit dann über die weihnachts-
und silvesterzeit wir können da
verabredung aussehen bis dann weit in
den januar hinein also genau das von
woche zu woche neu entscheiden müssen
und zu immer neuen massnahmen kommen
wollen wir alle miteinander vermeiden
und dafür gibt es auch ein vorschlag der
jetzt deutlich langfristiger ist als das
was wir bisher hatten
jetzt bleibt ja das ganz große
grundproblem ich habe es vorhin schon
kurz gesagt wir wissen einfach nicht
genau warum die infektionszahlen nicht
wirklich runter gehen nicht wirklich
sinken
haben sie den eindruck sie haben für
alle ihre weitreichenden entscheidungen
denn überhaupt genug datenbasis oder
stochern sie am ende wie wir alle wie
auch die virologen im nebel ein gutes
gibt ja schon erkenntnisse und sagen wir
mal es verdichten sich ja nach wie vor
dinge wo man sieht dass kontakte einfach
eine ent eine große rolle spielen bei
der ganzen infektions dynamik bestimmt
nicht die einzige und man wird es auch
nicht
nur auf eine gruppe oder ein umstand
begrenzen können wo dann die infektion
herkommen aber besondere dynamiken
werden natürlich schon von größeren
gruppen von vielen kontakten ausgelöst
will sehen wie unterschiedlich die
infektions dynamik in den
unterschiedlichen altersgruppen ist und
wie diejenigen dann auch erkrankten
teilweise auch schwer erkranken
daraus kann man ja rückschlüsse ziehen
dass man eben ganz besonders auf die
situation auch reagiert wo jüngere
menschen nun mal auch zusammenkommen mit
vielen kontakten auch im öffentlichen
leben dass man besonders achten muss auf
die älteren die wenn sie erkranken dann
auch schwer erkranken und aus diesem
jahr aus diesem bild das sich ergibt
ergibt sich dann eben auch der maßnahmen
mix gezielt an den jeweils sensiblen
stellen auch zu reagieren
gezielt an sensiblen stellen sagen sie
ich würd es ganz schlecht noch ein klein
bisschen konkreter machen vielleicht
gehen wir es mal durch wenn wir diesen
teilweisen shot down aktuell der nicht
ganz so gut funktioniert wie wir uns
alle wünschen vergleichen mit dem
teilweisen shutdown im frühjahr dann
gibt's natürlich viele faktoren die da
jetzt unterschiedlich sind ein
entscheidender oder ein wichtiger auf
denen auch zunehmend virologen hinweisen
das sind die schulen die waren im
frühjahr mal geschlossen die sind jetzt
offen sie sollen auch offen bleiben aus
sehr vielen guten gründen ist denn wenn
sie jetzt auch im zunehmend studien
lesen dass das infektionsrisiko an
schulen doch größer sein könnte als
gedacht
geraten die schulen auch in ihr
blickfeld jetzt stärker ein
ja man kann es nicht komplett
ausklammern und insbesondere in den
älteren jahrgängen da gibt es ja dann
auch schon ein sozialverhalten die bei
den erwachsenen und natürlich kann und
muss man da auch reagieren wir sehen zum
glück dass in den kitas und grundschulen
es wenig infektion gibt und vor allen
dingen dann auch wenig infektion mit
erkrankungen je älter die kinder werden
desto mehr spielt schon eine rolle
auch die infektions tätigkeit in die
familie und von der familie wieder in
die schule also dass man dort wiederum
unterscheidet und sagt wir wollen bei
den kleinen anders vorgehen auf jeden
fall den präsenzunterricht erhalten aus
sozialen gründen vor allen dingen auch
und bei den älteren die sich durchaus
auch alleine zu hause versorgen können
die mit den digitalen medien
entsprechend umgehen können dort biete
wir ein hybrid oder ein wechsel
unterricht an das finde ich ist ein
vorgehen mit augenmaß und um eben auch
wieder die besondere infektionsgefahr in
einer bestimmten gruppe von jugendlichen
oder jungen erwachsenen aufzunehmen zum
schluss noch ganz kurz herr müller hier
kollege armin laschet nrw hat heute
gesagt es wird das härteste weihnachten
das nachkriegsgenerationen je erlebt
haben hat der mann recht oder greift er
rhetorisch doch ein bisschen hoch ja ich
kann mich immer so einer rhetorik nicht
ganz anschließen weil wir es ja
einordnen müssen natürlich ist das eine
bedrückende situation die sich keiner
von uns gewünscht hat aber man muss auf
der anderen seite ja auch mal sehen was
wir erreicht haben
wir sind im internationalen vergleich
mit unserem weg auch immer mal wieder
nach zu steuern dass eine zu ermöglichen
das andere nicht zu ermöglichen doch
sehr gut gefahren und wir haben vielen
menschen helfen können und wir haben sie
geschützt und ich finde das rechtfertigt
dann auch dass wir gemeinsam die ein
oder anderen einschränkungen auch über
weihnachten tragen der vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz berlins
regierender bürgermeister michael müller
danke ihnen für das gespräch nach berlin
gehen ja mit neuen und längeren
beschränkungen kommt auch die frage wie
hilft man denen die jetzt bereits vor
dem wirtschaftlichen abgrund stehen
kommen nach den sogenannten november
hilfen die dezember hilfen martinsen
zeigt dass all das bei weitem nicht so
einfach ist und das ist nicht nur
restaurants theater weihnachtsmärkte
trifft sondern vielmehr branchen die
dahinter stehen zigtausende überall in
diesem land
nichts dreht sich nichts bewegt sich in
der hammonia wäschereien hamburg stehen
die maschinen still
mit dem teilstaat down bricht dem auf
hotel und gastronomie wäsche
spezialisierten familienunternehmen die
geschäftsgrundlage weg von 125 tonnen
bettwäsche handtücher tischdecken und
servietten pro woche sind noch zehn
übrig zu wenig für 70 angestellte wir
arbeiten momentan einen halben tag in
etwa in der woche um diese zehn tonnen
zu bearbeiten und die rest der zeit sind
alle in kurzarbeit
weithin sichtbares symbol des
stillstands die elbphilharmonie keine
konzerte keine touristenströme
das spüren sie im hotel der lp deutlich
mit den wenigen geschäftsreisenden liegt
die auslastung im einstelligen
prozentbereich bei nahezu
gleichbleibenden fixkosten wo es geht
werden vor allem externe
dienstleistungen heruntergefahren und
das sind in einem hotelbetrieb nicht
wenige veranstaltungstechnik und nicht
zuletzt natürlich auch unsere
lebensmittel und getränke händler die
uns beliefern
im frischeparadies im hamburger hafen
etwa machen hotel und restaurant kirchen
normalerweise 70 prozent des umsatzes
aus doch das bisschen take away geschäft
mit dem sich die gastronomie über wasser
zu halten versucht für die lücken in den
auftragsbüchern nicht ansatzweise auch
hier sind drei viertel der belegschaft
in kurzarbeit
wir haben seit dem neuen lockdown so gut
wie nicht mehr zu tun wenn wir früher
zirka vier tonnen am tag bewegt haben
dann bewegen wir heute vielleicht noch
250 kilogramm und die aufträge sind sehr
sehr klein weil natürlich auch unsere
gastronomen und hotels alle deutlich
weniger zu tun haben sie gar nichts mehr
zu tun haben die schließungen im hotel
und gastgewerbe erzeugen eine
kettenreaktion mit erheblichen
gesamtwirtschaftlichen folgen die ganze
wirtschaft in deutschland ungefähr 45
milliarden euro im jahr auf jeden
einzelnen euro kommen dann noch mal fast
90 cent dazu die zulieferbranche wie
indirekt produziert werden also wohl der
zulieferer nur deshalb geschäft hat zwei
die gastronomie nachfrage hat wohl der
mitarbeiter aus der gastronomie anwalt
sowie der nachfrage erzeugt und damit
die wirtschaft dem kleinen bild
wirtschaftlicher schaden des erneuten
stillstand in der branche rund 7,5
milliarden euro
die zugesagte november hilfe der
bundesregierung rettet die harmonia
wäscherei über den monat wird der teil
shutdown ohne weitere hilfen verlängert
droht aus dem schaden ein totalschaden
zu werden
die toten dieser pandemie erscheinen als
zahlen in den nachrichten auch bei uns
hier welche schicksale dahinter stehen
was all das für die hinterbliebenen
bedeutet darüber sagen die zahlen nichts
wichtig beim abschied nehmen sind
rituale unser erster reflex den anderen
in den arm nehmen
berührungen helfen oft mehr als worte
und sie fehlen jetzt noch mal ganz
besonderes und gerade denen die trauern
müssen in traurigen zeiten wie sibylle
bassler zeigt immer wieder gebe es
momente sagt sabine gaßner der seite der
großvater sehr nahe
bilder tauchen dann von ihm auf ein
lebensfroher mensch der sich in seinem
seniorenheim aufgehoben fühlt bis anfang
april die nachricht kommt der 83 jährige
hat sich mit corona infiziert dann hat
der zustand sehr schnell verschlechtert
und ja erst dann auch verstorben mitte
april
es ist sehr schwer damit umzugehen dass
man sich nicht verabschieden konnte
vorher von den erkrankten stadt abschied
nehmen zu können ist da nur leere
dann trifft sie eine zweite
hiobsbotschaft kurz darauf hat sich auch
mein schwiegervater in spe angesteckt
und es dann auch daran verstorben
das heißt sie haben gleich zweimal
seinen schlimmsten ausgang der krankheit
miterleben müssen sterben tod trauer das
leid verlangt von angehörigen und
schwerkranken schier unvorstellbares
gerade zu beginn der pandemie als
krankenhäuser und altenheime für die
außenwelt verschlossen sind
es gibt keinen zuspruch keine umarmung
einen abschiedskuss die vorstellung den
sterbenden
eingelassen zu haben ist bedrückend weil
er nicht nur in der stunde des todes
nicht dabei sein konnte sondern die
ganzen wochen sage mir vorher schon
nicht
dahinter steckt sehr viel schuldgefühl
in den angehörigen darin dass sie sagen
ich bin meiner verpflichtung als
angehörige nicht nachgekommen und autor
muss muss sie befreien und muss ihnen
sagen du hast keinen fehler gemacht
corona habe die trauerkultur verändert
so schießler für alle deren angehörige
in diesen zeiten versterben der tod
findet im kleinen stadt die rituale des
abschieds sind eingeschränkt eine offene
aufbahrung nicht möglich
trauergottesdienste selten die zahl der
trauergäste reduziert sind zehn fünfzehn
leute je nach möglichkeit die nach größe
des friedhofs und der trauerhalle und
die die kommen sind ganz bewusste bei
auch der großvater von sabine und ihrer
schwester julia wird im engsten kreis
beerdigt steht mehr abstand ein
schmerzliches erlebnis
umso mehr trifft es sie wenn menschen
corona verleugnen
auch deshalb sei es ihr wichtig über
ihre trauer zu sprechen dass die leute
sehen hinter dieser zahl der toten da
stecken aufrechte menschen echte
angehörige und echtes leid für die
statistik ist er einer der über 14.000
menschen die bisher in deutschland durch
kubik 19 gestorben sind für sie ist es
ihr großvater anteil nehmen ohne dabei
sein zu können ende ohne abschied was
uns corona kostet ist kaum noch fassbar
und das gilt auch im ganz schnöden rein
finanziellen sinn erstens weil die
zahlen so gigantisch sind und zweitens
weil niemand wirklich sagen kann ob all
das geld tatsächlich reicht am ende die
neuverschuldung des bundes im kommenden
jahr jedenfalls muss jetzt neu gerechnet
werden 160 milliarden euro an neuen
schulden 1 und damit über 60 milliarden
mehr als bisher bekannt dafür gebe es
vor allem zwei gründe zum einen stiegen
die kosten für wirtschaftshilfen im zuge
der korona krise zum anderen würden
ausgaben ins kommende jahr verschoben
scholz selbst sagte
für 2020 21 zusammen genommen werde der
korridor ungefähr der gleiche bleiben
eine gerechtere verteilung von corona
impfstoffe die unterstützung ärmerer
länder und den kampf gegen den
klimawandel
dass alle schreiben sich die g20-staaten
auf die fahne in der abschlusserklärung
nach ihrem video gipfel die konkrete
maßnahmen aussehen und finanziert werden
sollen das lesen die teilnehmer
allerdings offen
zuvor hatte us-präsident trump seinen
video auftritt für eine attacke gegen
das un klimaabkommen gewürzt
es sei unfair und ziele darauf ab die
amerikanische wirtschaft zu töten
tom cruise war auch dieser sonntag ein
protest sonntag der fünfzehnte in folge
wegen der massiven polizeipräsenz
versammelten sich die demonstranten
zunächst in wohnvierteln und innenhöfen
und zogen von dort aus durch die
hauptstadt minsk menschenrechtler
berichten von mehr als 300 festnahmen
die demonstranten fordern ein ende der
polizeigewalt die freilassung aller
politischen gefangenen und den rücktritt
von präsident lukaschenko dem sie
wahlbetrug vorwerfen
in guatemala sind proteste gegen den
neuen staatshaushalt eskaliert hunderte
demonstranten stürmten das
parlamentsgebäude und legten feuer
die rede ist von mindestens 14
verletzten insgesamt waren tausende
menschen auf die straße gegangen um den
rücktritt von präsident assad zu fordern
seine regierung hatte einen
rekordhaushalt durch das parlament
gebracht der dem land hohe schulden
aufbürdet im gesundheits und
bildungssektor aber ausgaben kürzt
zurück nach deutschland neue breite
wählerschichten ansprechen ohne die
eigene basis zu verprellen einen
machtanspruch formulieren ohne die
überzeugungen zu verwässern
das ist ein drahtseilakt und das ist
exakt die aufgabe vor der die grünen an
diesem wochenende standen zum vierten
mal in ihrer 40 jährigen geschichte hat
sich die partei ein neues
grundsatzprogramm gegeben
das inhaltliche fundament für 100.000
mitglieder und die startrampe für den
bundestagswahlkampf
und das alles auf einem parteitag der
nichts mehr hatte von erbitterten
diskussionen früher und strickenden
hitzköpfen dafür viel disziplin
verlangte nicht nur mit der technik aus
berlin christian von rächen wird
das ist 16 uhr als man im berliner
tempodrom plötzlich etwas hört applaus
geräusche waren auf diesem online partei
nun ist es klar das neue
grundsatzprogramm der grünen mit großer
mehrheit verabschiedet man kann auch
sagen fast ohne gegenwehr sind dieses
programm sollte nicht die vorsitzenden
stärken sondern sollte unsere partei
dafür stark machen dass wir für das
nächste jahr einen führungsanspruch
haben und dass wir eine grundlage für
das nächste jahrzehnt schaffen
platz nehmen am regierungstisch neue
wlan holen dafür mussten die grünen den
wohlfühlbereich verlassen uns
grundsätzliche gehen hätte auch
schiefgehen können
also ich glaube ist eine in der
beobachtung manchmal ein irrtum wenn wir
uns streiten dann heißt das nicht dass
wir uns zerstreiten und zerlegen wenn
wir uns streiten in der partei dann ist
das der weg zu neuer geschlossenheit
trotzdem scheint das thema klima so
heikel das ist die vorsitzende lieber
separat wegverhandelt kompromiss mit den
partnern zum abstimmen blieb er genug
übrig wahlalter auf 16 zu homöopathie
geht man auf abstand
bei der frage nach dem volksentscheid
aber wird's eng und laut und ich habe
mich tiere stellt jürgen trittin bringt
erst mit der technik dann mit dem thema
die antragsteller wollen ein wechsel des
betriebssystems die entscheidung der
frei gewählten abgeordneten der soll
konkurrenz gemacht
ich bin dir also da führt hier die angst
vor den wunsch des mitmachens um mit
bestimmten menschen absolut am ende
stimmt die partei knapp gegen
volksentscheide und mach die tür einen
spalt auf zur genforschung wieder folgt
die partei dem leitantrag eine der
wenigen änderungen erreicht die grüne
jugend sie bekommt kostenfreie schulen
und kitas zu irgendwas bildung ein
grundrecht das muss eben für alle auch
kostenlos zur verfügung stehen
und auch das grundeinkommen kommt ins
grundsatzprogramm wenn auch nur als
leitidee sie wollten es gar nicht egal
ihre größte sorge war angeblich ohnehin
die technik zu recht wo den spott müssen
sie nicht mehr sorgen haben immer noch
ein problem das lob für die mut haben
sie sich verdient sie haben viel
aufgelockert es war ein tolle videos mit
dabei und das hat dann schon auch leicht
gemacht es fehlen einfach die gespräche
tatsächlich draußen im foyer durch die
gänge gehen leute treffen die man schon
lange nicht getroffen hat sie brechen
also auf in die breite sicherheit
sozialstaat solidarität viele sorten
grün
sie nennen es die farbe der zeit dass
schwarz dazwischen ausgenommen schauen
wir noch auf den sport zuerst auf die
zwei sonntagsspiele in der
fußball-bundesliga bei denen ist zwei
heimniederlagen gab köln verlor gegen
union berlin mit 1 zu 2 und freiburg
unterlag mainz zuhause mit 1 zu 3 markus
eisenbichler hat den deutschen
skispringern einen sieg beschert und das
schon beim ersten einzel-weltcup der
saison
der 29 jährige sprang im polnischen
wisla 137 ein halb und 134 meter weit
damit lag er vor seinem teamkollegen
karl geiger und dem österreicher daniel
gruber nächste weltcup station ist in
einer woche das finnische ungarn und
auch die deutschen bob piloten konnten
einen doppelsieg feiern beim weltcup
auftakt im lettischen sigulda rekord
weltmeister francesco friedrich fuhr mit
anschieber alexander schiller auf platz
eins vor dem stuttgarter johannes
lochner der nach dem ersten durchgang
noch vorne gelegen hatte corinna bedingt
waren in sigulda weniger schlitten am
start als üblich während wir hier 2020
gegen das fernweh kämpfen und der
wanderausflug in die mittelgebirge
zunehmend als traumreise erscheint
machen sich andere auf 45.000 kilometer
einmal rund um die erde
und zwar so einfach mal raus kommen hat
er gleich eine neue bedeutung das letzte
ganz große abenteuer über 8000 menschen
standen schon auf dem mount everest fast
600 menschen waren allemal
aber erst 88 segler haben diese irre
wettfahrt zu ende gebracht nonstop und
ohne fremde hilfe ganz allein mit dem
boot dem meer und der einsamkeit
zum ersten mal ist ein deutscher dabei
und zwar gleich dermaßen erfolgreich
dass er jetzt sein schiff geküsst hat
weil es so toll läuft
hermann falk user hat die bilder boris
herrmann und das meer ganz allein im
segelboot einmal um die welt
erster deutscher bei der vendée globe
der atemberaubenden regatta der extreme
seine rennmaschine ein hochmodernes
segeln das boot mit flügeln
jetzt legen werden hauptsächlich mit
unserem forum hier nur noch das wasser
und ein bisschen mit dem heck das ist
hier rowland und keinster weise
heute vor zwei wochen sind in frankreich
33 boote gestartet 27 männer sechs
frauen knapp 45.000 kilometer oft
gesteuert vom autopiloten aber hilfe von
außen ist verboten
inzwischen nehmen sie kurs aufs kap der
guten hoffnung danach droht das
südpolarmeer mit eisigen temperaturen
und hohen wellen in 70 bis 80 tagen um
die welt alleine mit den elementen
schließlich der sogenannte vorhof zur
hölle das kap hoorn sie mit bis zu 75
kilometer pro stunde zurück jahren etwa
die hälfte der starter wird es schaffen
bis ins ziel
die ersten stürme kamen schnell anders
als ein paar mit favoriten hat der
gebürtige oldenburger sie unbeschadet
umschifft schlafen im höllenlärm immer
nur wenige minuten das hat boris
herrmann jahre lang trainiert das
vertrauen in sein boot auch
tonnenschwere lasten bewegt er mit hilfe
von umlenkrolle zum trimmen der zwei
tennisplätze großen segelfläche sein
schiff voll gepackt mit hightech aber
finden muss er seinen weg durch wind und
wetter sind
etwa ein drittel der strecke liegt
hinter der spitzengruppe
hermann hat seine schier explorer in der
animation das graue brötchen jenseits
des äquators auf rang sechs manövriert
und in kaum befahrene meeres bereiche
auch im dienst der wissenschaft diese
forschungsbudget soll erkenntnisse zur
erderwärmung durch co2 weite wege
lebensmotto ziele hat der 39 jahre alte
segler ja ohnehin bei dieser
unternehmung
na dann gute reise noch bis mindestens
mitte januar
[Musik]
wahnsinn ob das jetzt fernweh stillen
konnte wahrscheinlicher ist dass es das
gerade erst angefacht hat gucken wir auf
eine novemberwoche die jetzt vor uns
liegt am mittwoch ist klar wie es mit
dem chor ohne beschränkungen in
deutschland weitergeht darüber habe er
bereits ausführlich berichtet heute in
der sendung was sonst noch wichtig wird
jana becker hat den ausblick
[Musik]
ab montag wird in frankreich ein
ehemaliger staatspräsident vor gericht
stehen erstmals in der geschichte
frankreichs fünfte republik der vorwurf
an den cola sarkozy korruption er soll
2014 ein staatsanwalt in einem gegen ihn
laufenden ermittlungsverfahren bestochen
haben sarkozy droht eine haftstrafe von
bis zu zehn jahren und eine million euro
geldbuße
[Musik]
am freitag wird das rennen um den cdu
vorsitz in die nächste runde gehen in
einer live veranstaltung stellt sich
friedrich merz den fragen der cdu
mitglieder die gelegenheit seine
kritiker zu überzeugen
im dezember sollen die nächsten live
stream runden mit norbert röttgen und
armin laschet folgen
ebenfalls am freitag freuen sich viele
auf eine schnäppchenjagd am black friday
in den usa stürmen in anderen jahren
schnäppchenjäger die geschäfte
traditionell einen tag nach thanksgiving
mittlerweile ist der black friday auch
fest in deutschland verankert sowohl am
freitag selbst als auch an den rabatt
tagen davor wird corona bedingt ein
rekord an online verkäufen erwartet
[Musik]
ja das wetter gibt es sogar umsonst
dafür muss man dann aber auch nehmen was
man bekommt hier sind die aussichten die
neue woche startet mit vielen wolken und
etwas regen an den küsten gibt es
einzelne schauer im norden und am
alpenrand wird es länger freundlich zwei
bis elf grad danach stellt sich ruhiges
novemberwetter ein mit einer mischung
aus sonne wolken und zehn nebelfeldern
die temperaturen bleiben ähnlich dem
heute-journal heißen die aussichten
nächste woche marietta slomka und heinz
wolf im namen des ganzen teams danken
wir zwei für hier groß sind
[Musik]